what a coincidence
so it's you i'm fighting depends
on what if you want to get splattered
if so and lace up lay down some cash and
let's have some
fun
if we're doing this it's for serious
scratch i'm up in the stakes
oh i see you're not joking around
no problem i'll sweeten the pot
come with me
[Music]
you two are ready to start
yeah ready as i'll ever
brawler
no surprise there
[Music]
hey a coincidence
so it's you i'm fighting depends
on what if you want to get splattered
if so and lace up lay down some cash and
let's have some fun
if we're doing this it's for serious
scratch i'm
oh come with me
[Music]
you two are ready to start
[Music]
is
[Music]
yeah ready as i'll ever be
may the best brawler win
[Music]
fighters
[Music]
[Music]
ah
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
stop i'm done i surrender
this fight is over c is the winner
that was a doozy fee
got me grinning like a goon here to here
here's your take you earned every
emmy
thanks you're real bozo you know that
ozab a what and you're mr
normal don't turn your nose up at me